hey dr. Berg here this video we're going
to talk about fat thighs and a fat butt
alright so if you know of anyone that
has that have them watch this video
because as you age you're going to find
out that it's harder and harder to get
lean especially in the lower part of
your body and let's first talk about
some facts in the body okay some these
are physiological facts number one the
most that you can burn as far as actual
fat per week is two pounds okay so you
can't burn five pounds of fat a week
it's impossible if you are losing more
than two pounds a week it's just water
weight so just realize that okay so two
pounds is the most and that's for a good
healthy body with a good metabolism so
if you're not burning two pounds don't
get frustrated it could be just that
your your metabolism is kind of broken
and you might only burn one pound or
less as you build up your health but the
fact is that that's the most you can
burn per week all right now number two
in order to burn fat your body has to be
energetic it has to be sleeping it can't
be burnt out if you're tired and you're
not sleeping chances are you're not
going to be burn fat because it takes a
lot of energy to get the metabolism to
start burning this stuff off so you
really have to get healthy first before
you can start losing weight third in
order to burn fat you can't have
cravings when you're craving breads
pastas cereal what you're running on is
you're running on sugar fuel you're not
burning fat the way you know you're
burning fat is when you don't have the
cravings and the way you get rid of
cravings is we increase the greens and
the potassium in the body by a factor of
seven cups a day and the cravings should
go down but the point is that you
there's no way you're going to burn fat
when you have in these cravings and
you're starving and you're hungry all
the time that's not going to work okay
next thing is the body will always build
back the muscle if it the muscle is
wasting away before the fat okay now
what is that that brings us to our next
point there's a huge difference between
fat
on your body and maybe cellulite let's
just call it cellulite and atrophy now
atrophy is the wasting or or sagging of
your muscles in other words when a
muscles after atrophied it's sagging
it's weak it's hanging there and that's
really what a lot of people have and
they think that it's all just cellulite
and fat when in fact it's just an
atrophied muscle okay so because the
muscle is breaking down why because of
the stress hormones of age will tend to
make everything kind of droop and and
it's hard to get it lean okay so when
we're trying to lose weight we want to
identify what the real problem is
because if you think it's fat and you
start trying to burn this off you're
going to be very frustrated when it
doesn't work so let's take a look at
this atrophy a little bit more and how
we can undo it in the body there's two
things that happen you have a breakdown
of muscle and then we have a build
building back up of muscle okay so when
we exercise when we go through stress it
breaks things down there's a name for
that it's called catabolic I like a
cannibalistic your body is eating itself
up so it breaks things down it's a
breaking down catabolic and that happens
during the day and then at night when
you're resting you should build things
back up and so that's when you're
burning fat but that's when the muscle
starts building buck back up and that's
called anabolic and you may be heard
that from like anabolic steroids or
something like that big your body makes
certain hormones that build things back
up so really a person as they hit the
age of 50 during menopause and they get
atrophy they have a problem with this
anabolic catabolic thing they have too
much breakdown but not enough building
back up okay why because the hormones
are messed up so what can we do to
improve that number one we do not want
to exercise every day you don't want to
over train you want to take less
frequent workouts and space it out and
get more recovery so we want to recover
longer we want to rest longer we don't
want to exercise over soreness why
because when you're sore that means your
body is still in a catabolic state
now to speed up the anabolic phase where
we build back up the muscles there are
certain amino acids that you can consume
at the health food store and you can get
these even as a one supplement you have
to find them but the one that you need
and I would buy this as a single source
of three different amino acids leucine
leucine is an amino acid that helps
restore muscle tissue isoleucine is
another recovery amino acid these are
proteins in valine which will also
increase the muscle repair so find a
supplement with all three of these and
I'll type them out down here on the and
the blog you can just click read more
and get it and then also you even want
the cofactors because there's also
associated things with these amino acids
that help them work better and that's
called a cofactor its associated vitamin
like b3 and a b3 b6 and vitamin C so
find a supplement with leucine
isoleucine valine b3 b6 and vitamin C
and start taking that before you go to
bed every night even when you're not
working out to speed up the process of
recovery that will help the workouts
work better and then you want to workout
less so I recommend just workout until
your the soreness goes away and it could
be once a week it could be once every
two weeks when you start out but as you
do this more it'll get better and better
and better
the other thing you want to take is
omega-3 that's that flax oil because the
flax oil is really good to repair not
just the muscle but all the little
structures in the muscle to help you
like the energy factories the metabolism
factories so we want those omega-3 fatty
acids to take a little flax before you
go to bed and these amino acids you can
get them from the health food store
okay so the body will build back the
muscle first before the actual fats burn
and that is why people get frustrated
because they think it's not working but
it's really working their muscles are
getting leaner or stronger but they're
heavier so the scale doesn't move that
they're shrinking in size that's a good
thing and that actually must happen in
the beginning especially if your body is
broken down so don't take that as a loss
just go by size
measurement and also go by maybe how you
look less sagging muscles but and that's
why people don't necessarily lose the
weight right away that could it take six
weeks it could take eight weeks
to be before you start losing weight on
some cases because the muscles are so
atrophied that it takes time okay so
don't give up apply this information and
send me your success stories